bonjour ni cabaye est directeur
commercial de la société oyster océan
indien côté technologique études et
réalisations on a plusieurs produits
vidéosurveillance alarme intrusion nous
étions présents au salon de la maison
afin de présenter un produit innovant
selecta dna l'adn synthétique qui a été
vu à la tv pour le marquage des objets
usuels et de fortes valeurs nous vous
présentons aujourd'hui la mac briques
comme à l'intérieur des de la
vidéosurveillance avec la toute nouvelle
génération la 360 panomorphe le
visionnage et complet sur 360 degrés
nous sommes une entreprise réunionnaise
tout nouvellement créée il ya trois mois
et nous recherchons aujourd'hui de
développer dans la sécurité électronique
caméras de vidéosurveillance et
d'alarmé intrusion sur toute l'île de la
réunion
aujourd'hui je recherche de commerciaux
basés dans l'est et un dans l'ouest qui
nous permettront de diffuser l'ensemble
de nos produits sur toute l'île de la
réunion est de permettre aussi de faire
connaître aux hipsters nous mettons en
place une formation en interne qui
viendra compléter la formation de
commercial que vous avez les débutants
sont bienvenus nous assurons une
formation complète sur nos produits nous
recherchons donc des commerciaux
indépendants véhiculer et autonomes dans
leurs démarches si vous souhaitez
intégrer une équipe jeune et dynamique
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter